- You don't have time?
What the fuck are you talking about?
All my... You know, I'm
a fucker, I'm crazy.
I have people that say...
I'll go see somebody leave
a comment to my Vice.
say they don't have time,
then I'll follow them.
(crowd laughing)
And then I wait like a fucking hawk.
This is actually my favorite,
like a fucking cobra in the grass.
Do you know how sick I am?
This is what I do with
my fucking spare time.
Charles Joseph fucking wrote,
"I don't have time for this."
And I fucking get motivated by that.
Follow him on Twitter.
He's got eight followers, right.
And I watch him and then I wait,
and this is my favorite time of year,
this actually is my favorite time of year
because a lot of them love to talk
about Steph Curry and Lebron.
And I'll wait and I'll wait
and then the Tweet will come.
"Yo! Did you just see what Lebron did?"
And I fucking strike.
(crowd laughing)
And I jump in, I'm like,
"Oh, you don't have time
but you have time for Lebron, you fucker?"
(crowd laughing)